do you think body count matters no
no no okay what is a high number for
body count
would you say
because i don't because i say that it
doesn't matter
no matter like whatever number you have
like it doesn't matter okay 50
what do i have to do with that that's in
the past i'm sorry for a woman what do
you think a high body count is
i don't
move i don't know i think everyone would
think like
10 would be a lot okay nowadays if some
guy met a girl now and be like oh what's
your body count
you know
10 hell is frozen over
i think 10 or 15 around there okay
that's what we've seen all right
um well if it really doesn't matter to
you then why should you have
you know
a body count if it doesn't matter but if
you know
in that case since i can answer this
question
for women
i guess
like
5 or 10 or 15 however much it takes them
to get satisfied
probably whatever number you say they'll
be like yeah that's last time see the
hard thing is they don't have good
numbers on like what the average body
count of the youth is today
because like the the way the average
body count they say for a girl is like
seven okay but
you
like based on like through people you
know
i don't i don't know about you but like
that that wouldn't be the average is
like what i would guess
because i know some girls that are
probably over like a stupid high number
right so you don't really know how it's
distributed and the other issue is that
the um
how did i put it like they take that
number from women from like age 20 to
age 70 80 90. those girls were like
i don't want to say a different cloth
because they still have birth control
they're so wild and to some degree but
like i don't know i feel like every
generation just starts a while the wild
and wild more
true
so it's like it's kind of a double-edged
sword yeah
so
with that um
in the uh
zachary i said we're uphill universe and
zachary's like yeah it's a universe
in the red pill sphere um for a high
value man which is someone that is make
six figures and six foot has six inches
and then zachary said has a six
to be a high volume
no then what is it am i saying it wrong
you're saying it right you're close
is it it's money frame i'm so proud of
her
sorry it's money
frame
so so you got this 10k per month so it's
120 a year
it's money money frame game that's
that's if a guy wants to be more
attractive to women that's it money
muscles okay gotcha that's what a guy
like has to do if he wants to up his
value okay but but high values you need
i i have some of these in front of me
this took me forever to memorize though
um 10k per month's a 120 per year and
that's adjusted so if he's in like a big
city like la new york it needs to i
don't know exactly what it is but it
needs to be more right the other thing
is that other men must accept you as
high value so like if you're just kind
of a loaner and you got no network you
don't count i don't know why i can't
tell you they just they don't count you
um so you need a network of high value
men other men must accept you you need
to be linked in level visibility because
otherwise you're not a high value you're
a man of value like some guys get their
money they don't want to talk to anyone
they go on their piece of land they
don't do anything
but that's different than like the ceo
of mergers and acquisitions
right vps like that that's that sort of
level and they have to be useful to the
group and to others okay
so that's that's a high value okay that
is a high volume man and then
when
when it comes to
body count
it's
23 years old or
that
which one which one for the body count
so a high volume man
looks at
actually i'll say this first so
when it comes to a body count
a high value man
looks at a body count and if it's if
it's on the lower side you're more
valuable as a woman because
every
one
man that you are with it is 19
uh women that a man is with essentially
that's how they calculate it yeah it's
like your ability to bond like enough
dudes
you're you're a guy right so you talk to
them and i talk to women more i you know
balance probabilities like you ever have
a guy that's slept with like six figure
girls and like he just can't really like
pair like that like he can't really bond
with my girls anymore that happens to
men too but like women it's just like
quicker because over history like what
do we have to do we need the highest
value guy in order to produce the best
offspring
where men they they were trying to
they're trying to [ __ ] these hoes you
know i mean like they're trying to
spread that they were trying to genghis
khan what was he doing
he was wilding in these streets
and so if you go throughout your 20s um
and you have over there's a lot of
people that said no more than 10 i think
12 was the most that i heard throughout
the day yeah we had two we
your your friend said 50. 15. nobody
said 50. who said 50. your friend said
50. it was one it was someone you were
on the phone with said no no no my mom
said 50. 50 what 50 uh
bodies i thought jess had 50.
she said 50. did you say 15 15 15. oh my
bad yeah
and so the more throughout your 20s the
more bodies you have the less valuable
you are as a woman to a high-value man
so you could have so the more you have
less the less you are because um
there's this thing called the wall and
you're 22 right yes so you're good um
okay i don't i don't know much about the
wall i just know i'm approaching it and
i'm like how do i knock it down and not
see it anymore so the wall is
essentially your
uh
what is it called something something
pink i can't remember yeah so it's
basically like as women we're going to
live to be 90 right and i think you know
as a young woman you just get more
attention from men right like like they
tend to be more attracted to you the
younger you are i mean i'm not talking
about like teenagers but like you're 22
you're going to get more attention than
a 42 year old
in general
jello is what
right
yeah exception though right like but the
average 42 year old mom if the guys had
to pick they're picking you look at you
well yeah
um fertility because they they surveyed
men between the ages of 20 and 70 and
they rate 22 23 and 24 year olds is the
most attractive across the board from
met like ages of 20 to 70.
um because they're attracted to
fertility right that's what they want so
um
but basically like when you hit the wall
it's a subconscious acknowledgement as a
woman that you can't compete the way you
did so when and this is it's sometimes
later for some people like jlo it hit
her later right obviously you know this
girl is fine forever but but it's
basically around the age of 30 girls
realize okay i got a couple more
wrinkles in my face like i'm a little
heavier than i was 10 years ago i don't
i don't look as good as i did and so
they realize mentally that they can't
compete with themselves from 10 years
ago so the guys that they're she was
pulling at 20 like she can't pull them
at 30 anymore and she's thinking you
know what i should probably find a guy
to settle down with
because otherwise like i'm not gonna get
a guy i want right so it's like like
girls just feel oh shoot girls just feel
the clock like ticking faster basically
is like what the wall is um okay but
what about the women that are in their
30s and 40s that decides that they would
rather go for younger men
oh that's amazing strategy for sure
because because young men like that
that's that's a very common and you're
going to see that more and more and more
because young men have less options like
because a lot of men said they didn't
realize how many [ __ ] they were going
to get when they got into their 30s
because they're like life gets so much
better because as a girl we wake up at
16 and boom we get all this attention
right i mean some girls more some girls
less but even an average looking girl
gets more attention than like most guys
yeah so when a guy hits 35 and he he's
gone to the gym for 10 years now he's
got muscles now he's learned to talk to
women a little better he's got game he's
learned you know he's dated a couple
girls so he knows how to like hold you
know you know how these hoes be like
like that we'd be tripping for no reason
but like like as a guy like at first
when you're younger you might like give
in and start like arguing with them but
like
holding your frame as a man is like
important for attraction and then money
right so you do all four of those things
by the time you're 35 you have your pick
of like 10 years or less
and like
um
so a mating strategy women will do is if
they're in their 30s and they're like oh
[ __ ]
my values gone down what's the way i can
get around this
i'm gonna go for the young guys the same
way like young guys go for the older
women it's like
and but then i've ever heard from young
guys and they're like yeah if i sleep
with an older woman she's planning on
our wedding basically in a week
because because like that's like because
she's got that clock ticking because
after 35 it's geriatric pregnancy so
what like you can't
like i mean
soon if you if you hit 35 like life
makes choices for you
and some people are lucky like my family
like my mom had kids into her 40s but
that's the exception it's not the norm
and the other
so
it's one thing to say i don't want kids
when you're young it's another thing to
like have that choice taken away and
your only option is ivf but what is ivf
it's 25k a year
and it might work it might not even work
so can the average person afford that
and so it's like feminism is pushing a
luxury lifestyle on average people the
kardashians can do that she had five
beautiful kids and she hired someone
else to care like they can do that but
that's not for the average person like
you and me like
are you done
so it's like
yeah and that's so that's like what
like the wall is basically like the the
party's over for women it's they're
realizing like like that they're you
they're
they're their beauty is going where men
men have that too it's just a little bit
later because women are we're still
attracted to you guys for money and
we're attracted to you guys for
power we're static like there's other
things that like we're attracted to that
men aren't aren't necessarily yeah
oh and the other thing is girls think
that like men care about their career
too because like you always
i know you're guys
[Music]
but like a career woman they're like oh
i have
all this money right and so they're
thinking like the same way we're
attracted to a man with money they'll
think they'll be attractive to men with
money then like they hit 30
35 whatever it is and they're like i
have all this money where's my husband
and they're like nah we just wanted a
girl that wasn't ran through and maybe
it was a bit younger
and like hot
and she's like what
um
so what about the men who actually makes
money
they more look at
women who aren't making money to match
their level of you know
what the [ __ ] can they call so so they
don't care like men it's like
if if a guy has a shoe collection i
don't care like that's cool you know i'm
sure you might look cool in your jordans
but like i'm not like oh i want to bang
that right but like girls want to bang
the president they want to bang the ceo
they like they're attracted to power and
maybe like maybe it's a rap or maybe
it's like whatever whatever their their
thing is right so
met like women it's more like women
don't want to date a guy that makes less
than them
because when women get promoted they're
they're like three times more likely to
get divorced
if they out earn their husbands yeah
yeah because like historically we had to
have a guy that we looked up to
so
it's not fun like i don't think that's
like a fun
reality but if you look at the data like
you can't deny it's there so i think men
don't necessarily
like need a girl that makes less than
them it's the the girls that make the
same don't usually want them and they
kind of look at them as like below
because i've had guys calling the show
and they say i wouldn't have a problem
with a girl that makes more than me but
it's like
she feels like she's better than me and
that's why i can't date her because she
acts like she's above me